[संगीत]
ओके सो हेलो एवरीवन
गुड इवनिंग
आई थिंक वे अरे गुड तो को नो
चलिए तो
ओके स्टार्ट करते हैं
उसके आगे हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे और फर्स्ट ऑफ
जो लाइक आई वुड लाइक तू इंट्रोड्यूस
माइसेल्फ तो मैं नितेश सिंह हूं और आई ऍम
फाउंडर ऑफ डिप्ट्रॉनिक्स बेसिकली और टुडे
और टुडे आज जो है हम
काफी एक इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक पढ़ने वाले हैं
आप लोग बस मुझे यह बता दीजिए की आप लोगों
को मेरी आवाज क्लियर तो जा रही है प्लीज
प्लीज बस ये बता दीजिए की आप लोगों को
मेरी आवाज क्लियर हो जाति है
ओके ठीक है थैंक्स ओके ग्रेट एकदम क्लियर
डायरेक्शन ठीक है इनपुट आउटपुट रीड
डायरेक्शन ओके
और उसको लाइक एक सेशन में कंप्लीट नहीं
किया जा सकता है मैं सामान्य हूं तो इस
सेशन में जितना हम कर सकते हैं
सबसे पहले वे आर गोइंग तू अंडरस्टैंड की
यह इनपुट आउटपुट डायरेक्शन जो है ना
बेसिकली कहां पर कम आने वाला है किस तरीके
से कम आने वाला है वो साड़ी चीज समझेंगे
अभी देखो अभी क्या होता है अभी
और यहां पर
यहां पर हम बात करते हैं इनपुट आउटपुट
रीडायरेक्शन की ठीक
है
इनपुट आउटपुट रिडक्शन व्हाट इसे दिस इनपुट
आउटपुट रे डायरेक्शन ठीक है नो
आप अपने सिस्टम में आप सबको पता होगा की
एक इनपुट डिवाइस होती है एक आउटपुट डिवाइस
होती है यह बहुत ही बेसिक सा कॉन्सेप्ट है
बहुत ही बेसिक सा कॉन्सेप्ट है बहुत बेसिक
सा और उसको बस समझना है ठीक है इनपुट
डिवाइस जहां से हम इनपुट लेते हैं आउटपुट
डिवाइस जहां हमें आउटपुट मिलता है सिंपल
सिंपल
[संगीत]
डिवाइस और जनरल आउटपुट डिवाइस बहुत ही
बेसिक साइंस
हमारा कीबोर्ड होता है
बिल्कुल सही और बेसिक सा आउटपुट डिवाइस
होता है हमारा वह हमारा स्क्रीन होता है
सिंपल जो आपका स्क्रीन होता है या
डिस्प्ले होता है
ठीक है
इनपुट को और इसी आउटपुट को बस रीडायरेक्ट
करनी है बस यही इनपुट आउटपुट डायरेक्शन
में अब ये रे डायरेक्शन जो होती है ना ये
बहुत तरह के बहुत तरह से होती है बहुत तरह
का इसमें कॉन्सेप्ट है बहुत तरह की चीज
हैं लाइक अलग-अलग तरीके डेली मी का
दिलीमीटर कॉन्सेप्ट उसके बाद लाइक
यू कैन यू हैव कॉन्सेप्ट इसे देवर और भी
बहुत सारे लाइक
यू कैन से की मतलब की इसमें इतने
कॉन्सेप्ट है ना इतने की अगर हम उसको पूरा
डिटेल में पढ़ें तो एक सेशन में भाई
कंप्लीट नहीं होने वाला है काफी उसमें
टाइम लगे वाला है ठीक है तो मैं बिल्कुल
एकदम बेसिक से आपको लेक चल रहा हूं
बिल्कुल ये स्टार्ट से लेक चल रहा हूं और
आपको उसमें ट्राई करूंगा की आपको मैक्सिमम
चीज दे पाऊं ठीक है फिर से फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन वगैरा हो गया बहुत साड़ी चीज
अब यहां पे बात करते हैं सबसे पहले की ये
डायरेक्शन इनपुट इनपुट आउटपुट परीक्षण
होती कैसे हैं क्यों हमें जरूर पड़ती है
तो अभी देखो मैं इसका एक छोटा सा पहले
एग्जांपल दिखता हूं और फिर मैं आपको ये
चीज अच्छे से पहले समझता हूं ठीक है जैसे
मां लो मैंने एक टर्मिनल यहां पे ओपन किया
लेट सपोज यहां पे ये टर्मिनल ओपन किया आई
थिंक विजिबल होगा मैं थोड़ा सा इसका फोंट
और भी इंक्रीज कर देता हूं ठीक है मैंने
यहां पे क्या किया टर्मिनल ओपन कर लिया नो
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग तू डू मैं यहां पे एक
सिंपल सा लेट सपोज डेट का मां चलता हूं
सिंपल सा हमने डेट कमांड चलाया हमने जब
डेट कमांड चलाया तो हमने इनपुट कहां से
लिया हमने इनपुट लिया अपने कीबोर्ड से ठीक
है कम ऑन टाइप करने के लिए और हमें आउटपुट
कहां मिला हमें आउटपुट मिला यहां पे
टर्मिनल पे यानी की स्क्रीन पे तो हमारा
इनपुट डिवाइस कीबोर्ड आउटपुट हमारे
स्क्रीन अब हमें इसे रीडायरेक्ट करना है
रीड डायरेक्शन जो है ना बहुत ज्यादा
यूजफुल होती है जब आप थोड़ा सा दीप जाओगे
किड ऑफ की जब आप एरर चीयरिंग एरर लॉगिन ये
सब चीजों में जाओगे सिस्टम लोग सिस्टम एरर
लॉगिन करना हो या कोई प्रोग्राम एरर लॉगिन
करनी हो कैपचरिंग करनी हो इन सब चीजों में
इसका बहुत ज्यादा उसे होता है जनरली ठीक
है हम उसे करते हैं जनरली लाइक किसी भी
आउटपुट को किसी और के जगह किसी और फाइल
में सेंड कर देना किसी को ऐसे इनपुट ले
लेना अलग-अलग तरह की चीज है तो मां लो
मेरे पास डेट कम है बहुत ही सिंपल सा मैं
आपको समझता हूं ठीक है मां लो ये मेरा डेट
कमांड है अब मुझे क्या करना है ना इस डेट
कमांड को यहां आउटपुट जो है ना रीड
डायरेक्ट का मतलब क्या हुआ की जो एक आप
इनपुट ले रहे हो उसके आउटपुट को भी
डायरेक्ट और एक इनपुट को डायरेक्टर अगर आप
इनपुट को रीडायरेक्ट करना चाहते हो यानी
कोई और चीज कोई एक फाइल है उसकी इनपुट
किसी और में डालना चाहते हो वो कर सकते हो
और किसी आउटपुट को कहानी और डालना चाहते
हो फाइल में वो कर सकते हो सिंपल अपडेट
कमांड ए गई अब मुझे क्या करना है ना मैं
एलएस करता हूं डेस्कटॉप पे डेस्कटॉप पे
कोई सी भी ऐसी फाइल नहीं है यहां पे एलएस
आईफोन ए कर देते हैं तो ओबवियसली यहां कोई
फाइल नहीं है सिंपल सी चीज है अब मुझे
क्या करना है ना इस डेट कमांड को यहां पर
इंटर नहीं कर रहा मेरे को टर्मिनल पे ये
प्रिंट नहीं करना मेरे को डायरेक्ट
स्क्रीन पे ये प्रिंट नहीं करनी मुझे कहां
करनी है मुझे एक फाइल के अंदर करनी है लेट
सपोज तो मैं क्या करूंगा मैं एक ये एक
ग्रेटर दें वाली सिंबल उसे करूंगा और जो
भी फाइल में आपको इसको प्रिंट करने को
फाइल का नाम दे दूंगा जैसे मैंने दिया मैं
डेट डॉट टेक्सटाइल देता हूं डेट डॉट टी
एक्स टी ये फाइल लिया और इंटर कर दिया
सिंपल अब आप देखोगे तो एलएस करोगे तो आपको
एक फाइल क्रिएट होकर मिलेगी डेट डॉट टी
एक्स टी की थॉट्स आईटी अब इसके हम व्यू
करेंगे ना कैट स्पेस दे डॉट टेक्स्ट ये
फाइल व्यू करने का एक कमांड होता है अभी
आपको बहुत सारे कमांड जो है ना काली के वो
एकदम बेसिक से बताए जाएंगे ठीक है तो उसके
लिए आप थोड़ा टेंशन मत लेना की ये सर क्या
है कमांड क्या है सिंपल सा भी कमांड जानू
एलएस से कोई भी डायरेक्टरी जी लोकेशन पे
वहां की जो भी डायरेक्टर फाइल्स है उसको
व्यू करने के लिए अलेक्स कमांड उसे होता
है यहां पे हमने एक ग्रेटर दें का सिंबल
दिया ये बहुत ही यूजफुल सिंबल है इसके
बड़े में मैं डिटेल में बात करूंगा क्या
है ये क्यों भाई ये देने पे date.xp में
इसकी आउटपुट चली जाएगी और यहां पे हमने
कैट कमांड का उसे किया जो की बेसिकली जो
भी फाइल के कंटेंट्स हैं उसको सामने
स्क्रीन पे दिखा देता है तो मैंने कैट डेट
डॉट टेक्स्ट किया अब देखो यहां पे देख रहे
हैं ये डेट जो है प्रिंट होके डेट और टक्स
फाइल में प्रिंट हुई है देखो ये फाइल में
ओपन करता हूं ग्राफिकल ओपन करके दिखा देता
हूं ये देखो ये देख रहे हो यहां पे ये
यह फाइल देखो इसको मैं क्या कर देता हूं
लेट सपोज थोड़ा सा इसको फोंट में बड़ा कर
देता हूं ठीक यहां पर प्रिंट हो गया अब यह
जो डेट मैंने प्रिंट किया ना यह प्रिंट
मेरी स्क्रीन पर नहीं हुआ था डेट ये देखो
जब मैंने सिंपली यहां डेट करके ये कमांड
डाला तो दिस डेट दस नोट प्रिंट ऑन स्क्रीन
ये कहां हुआ डेट थी मैं प्रिंट हुआ अब ये
कॉन्सेप्ट बहुत सिंपल है लेकिन बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग है देखने में बहुत सिंपल ग
रहा है क्या वही जो इधर प्रिंट हो गया अब
एक चीज देखो मैं अभी पूरा डिटेल में आऊंगा
अब क्या करता हूं मैं यहां पे कैलेंडर का
मां चलता हूं ठीक है तो चलो इंस्टॉल नहीं
है तो मैं इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेट हूं कोई
बात नहीं कैलेंडर जो है और कल से आता है
ये पॉजिटिव से तो वहां से हमने कैलेंडर
कमांड को इंस्टॉल कर लिया ठीक है अब यहां
पे कैलेंडर कमांड का सी ए ल कमांड डालते
इसे कैलेंडर आप देख सकते हो ठीक है तो
मैंने जून 2023 का ये कैलेंडर यहां पे आगे
जो लेटेस्ट था अब मैं क्या करता हूं
कैलेंडर कमांड का आउटपुट को इस फाइल में
देने का कोशिश करता हूं डेट में और मैं
इंटर करता हूं अब मैंने किया अब ये उसमें
भी चला गया अब इस फाइल को ग्राफिकल एक बार
ओपन करके देखते हैं
यह देखो मैंने ग्राफिकल ओपन करके दिखाना
तो तुम्हें क्या कुछ दिखे रहा है यहां पर
यह मैं यह नंबर्स हटा देता हूं लाइन नंबर
अब ये दिखे रहा है डेट कमांड गायब हो गई
जो डेट कमांड के आउटपुट थी रे यह कंपलीटली
गायब हो गई और यहां पे कौन सा ए गया हमारे
पास यहां पर
तो डेट तो भैया गायब हो गया इसका मतलब
क्या हो रहा है की हमने जब ये कमांड चलाया
सिंपली
आई थिंक अपना टर्मिनल ओपन है क्या ओपन है
ये रहा हमने जब ये कमेंट चलाया तो इसलिए
क्या किया कैलेंडर कमांड के आउटपुट को डेट
डॉट टेक्स्ट में दाल दिया और जो पहले वाला
हमारा बेसिकली जो कमांड था उसको क्या किया
इसने रिप्लेस कर दिया जो उसने इसने
रिप्लेस कर दिया
उसको बाहर निकाल कर फेक दिया और इसको इसके
आउटपुट को दाल दिया बट अगर तुम्हें ये
चाहिए की नहीं मुझे बाहर नहीं फेंकना उसे
चीज को मुझे अब फिर से डेट कमांड जो है ना
इसकी आउटपुट को इसी में डालनी है बट
कैलेंडर वाला आउटपुट भी रहना चाहिए तो
इसके लिए हम डबल टाइम्स ग्रेटर डेन उसे
करते हैं और दें हम क्या करते हैं यहां पे
डेट डॉट टी एक्स टी दाल देते हैं इंटर
करते हैं अब जब हमने ये डबल टाइम्स का
किया ना तो इसका मतलब होता है अपेंड करना
और इसका मतलब होता है आउटपुट को रिप्लेस
करना ठीक है अभी मैं इस पे आऊंगा बहुत चीज
अभी बतानी अपडेट डॉट टेक्स्ट की ओपन करोगे
तो देखो यहां पे यहां पे एक तो कैलेंडर का
आउटपुट जो पहले से था वो तो है ही और उसके
बाद आपका जो डेट का आउटपुट है वो डेट का
आउटपुट भी यहां पे ए चुका है दोनों आउटपुट
आपके सामने यहां पे बेसिकली दिखे रही है
थॉट्स आईटी गो आईटी इतना तो नॉर्मली समझ
में ए गया होगा नॉर्मली यू माइट हैव
अंडरस्टूड की हां ये चीज नॉर्मली हो रही
है यहां पे चलो ठीक है अब समझते हैं
कॉन्सेप्ट को की ये चीज हैं क्या ये तो
मैंने आपको एग्जांपल बता दिया
ठीक है अब इसको इसके कॉन्सेप्ट को थोड़ा
समझते हैं देखो
इनपुट आउटपुट रे डायरेक्शन में आप जब
लिरिक्स की बात कर रहे हो ना तो यहां पे
ये जो सिंबल होती है यह जो ग्रेटर दें के
सिंबल होती है इसका मतलब होता है ओवरराइट
करना
ओवरराइट करना जो आपका आउटपुट है
आउटपुट को देना और ओवरराइट करना आउटपुट को
किसी फाइल में लेकर जाना बट वहां से
ओवरराइट करके वहां पर स्टोर करना और इसका
मतलब होता है
आपका
स्टडी आउट में वो बेसिकली अपेंड हो जाएगा
अब ये सीडी इन स्टडी आउट ये सब क्या है
अभी अभी समझ में ए जाएगा अभी थोड़ा मैं
क्लियर करूंगा आपको सर कुछ क्लियर हो
जाएगा अब देखो इन चीजों को ना ये जो आपको
चीज दिखे रही है ये ग्रेटर दें फिर से एक
और आएगा आपका ली दें उसके बाद डबल ग्रेटर
दें फिर डबल ली दें
यह जो चीज आपको दिखे रही है बेसिकली यह जो
चीज हैं गैस इनको हम रीडायरेक्ट सिंबल
बोलते हैं जो की फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन के लिए
कम करते हैं फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन के लिए ये
कम करते हैं फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
के सिंबल होते हैं ये फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
जो होते हैं उसके ये रीडायरेक्ट सिंबल
होते हैं अब दिमाग में किसी के क्वेश्चन
आया की भैया फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन क्या होता
है ये कौन सी है अभी तो इनपुट आउटपुट
रिएक्शन पढ़ रहे थे ना अपन व्हाट इस फाइव
डिस्क्रिप्टिव ये किसी का दिमाग में आया
क्वेश्चन किसी के चाट में मुझे अगर बोल
सकते हो तो बता दो किसी के दिमाग में आया
तो फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
क्या होता है तो फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन के
बड़े में थोड़ा सा समझते हैं अब देखो फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन के बड़े में भी जैसा की मैं
पहले ही बोला की टॉपिक उसे थिंक फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन अपने आप में उसे थिंक है
बहुत साड़ी कॉन्सेप्ट बहुत साड़ी चीज हैं
इसको बहुत सिंपल तरीके से हम समझना वाले
हैं की भैया फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
होता क्या है चलो
अच्छा आप लोग नोटबुक ओपन करके रखा है आप
लोगों ने जैसा की मैं बोलना हूं की आप
लोगों ने नोटबुक ओपन करके रखा है कहानी पे
नोट्स टाइप आप लिख सकते हो प्लीज ठीक है
तो आप लोगों को यह चीज राइट डॉ करनी है
ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा
फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन ठीक
है
लिखने में थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम ए रही है
तथा'एस वही तो उसको थोड़ा इग्नोर कीजिएगा
आप लोग बस समझिएगा चीजों को यह एक नंबर है
जो की बेसिकली आईडेंटिफाई करता है किसी भी
ओपन फाइल को आस के अंदर ओपन फाइल को
आईडेंटिफाई करता है
आईडेंटिफाई और
ओपन फाइल
एक प्रोसेस में है जो भी फाइल ऑलरेडी
प्रोसेस हो रही है जो भी फाइल उसे में ए
रही है ओपन फाइल है सिंपल तो यह उसको
आईडेंटिफाई करता है हमारा फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन अच्छा एक बात बताओ मुझे एक
मुझे आप लोग बात बताओ लिरिक्स में जो होती
है ना हर एक चीज अगर आपको नहीं पता आपको
लगता होगा डायरेक्टरी होती है फाइल होती
है अलग-अलग चीज होती है
मतलब दिमाग घुमा हर चीज डायरेक्टरी है ना
वह भी फाइल है तुम यह समझ के चलो अब वह
क्यों ऐसा है आपको बताता हूं जितने
फाइल बस उनको बेसिकली अब यह जो आपका यह जो
आपका एसटीडी इन है एसटीडी आउट है एसटीडी
एरर है ठीक है यह भी फाइल सी होते हैं यह
स्पेशल फाइल्स होते हैं
यह स्पेशल
फाइल्स होते हैं
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
के लिए मैंने जो बताया आप उसको ऐसे लिख
सकते हो
डिस्क्रिप्शन
अन्य डाटा अन्य डाटा सोर्सेस
ठीक है कोई भी डाटा सोर्स जो है उसको यह
बेसिकली डिस्क्राइब करता है या फिर यू कैन
से की इस को दिनो करता है ठीक है
उसे समय करनाल जो होती है ना करना
यह जो करनाल होता है उसे टाइम पर यह तीन
चीज करता है आपकी
ठीक है
एंट्री इन
ग्लोबल
फाइल टेबल
प्रोवाइड डी लोकेशन
ऑफ डी एंट्री
और तीसरा क्या करता है आपको लोकेशन
प्रोवाइड करता है
वह करता है जब भी कोई ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
कर रहे हो अगर आपको यह नहीं पता मैं इनपुट
इनपुट आउटपुट डायरेक्शन को मैसेज बताऊंगा
क्योंकि वो चीज आपको पता ही नहीं होगी
तो कॉन्सेप्ट समझना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है
और जैसा की हमने प्रॉमिस किया था की आपको
बेसिकली जो भी यह आपका कैप्सूल कोर्स होगा
इस चैनल के ऊपर में वॅटीवर टॉपिक इस देवर
डेट बिल बी
डिटेल मैनर चाहे उसमें टाइम हमें थोड़ा
ज्यादा ग जाए चलेगा बट वो डिटेल मैनर में
डील उसे पे हम करेंगे डिटेल मैनर में आपको
समझाएंगे आपको बताएंगे और आपको क्लियर
करेंगे थॉट्स आईटी तू चीज का फायदा उठाइए
और टुडे आई थिंक दे आर वेरी ली
प्रेजेंट्स सो आईएफ समवन इस देवर यू कैन
सेंड डी लिंक इन डी ग्रुप और की कम से कम
यार आपको फ्री की लर्निंग मिल रही है तो
एटलिस्ट जॉइन तो करो देखो तो लाइव का मजा
तो देखो अभी तो बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज आने
वाली है वो भी देखो क्या क्या चीज आने
वाली है राइट
तो यह तीन चीज करना हमारा भाई करता है
ठीक है तो जो फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
आईडेंटिफाई किया जाता है ठीक है अब इसको
भी थोड़ा समझते हैं
जो आपका सॉरी
जो आपकी फाइल
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन होता है
जो
स्क्रिप्ट होता है
[संगीत]
ये तीन पॉइंट बताए थे मैंने करनाल के एक
किसी ने पूछा 3 पॉइंट बताने के लिए दो और
तीन ठीक है क्रिएट्स एंटरिंग ग्लोबल फाइल
टेबल और प्रोवाइड डी लोकेशन ऑफ डी एंट्री
ये तीन चीज करनाल करता है ठीक है
आप लोग क्या करो अगर आप लोग इसको नहीं
टाइप कर सकते ना तो इसकी स्क्रीनशॉट ले
लिया करना जब भी कुछ लिखा हो सामने तो
इसको स्क्रीनशॉट ले लो दत बिल डू हेल्प इन
योर नोट्स ठीक है
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन होते हैं बेसिकली इनको
आईडेंटिफाई कैसे किया जाता है इनको
आईडेंटिफाई कैसे किया जाता है
आईडेंटिफिकेशन जो होता है इसका इसका होता
है
यूनिकॉर्न
नहीं होगा
नॉन नेगेटिव एंटीजर
बहुत परेशान किया था नॉन नेगेटिव
इनके द्वारा ये किया जाता है ठीक है
हर एक ओपन फाइल के लिए जो भी एक ओपन फाइल
है ना उसके लिए एक फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन करता
ही करता है करना ही करना है ठीक है एक
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन आपको करना ही करना है
डेट्स आईटी
ओके
सो मैं यहां पर एक बार परमिशन लाउड कर
देता हूं ताकि लिंक सेंड हो पे और
ओके हम सेंडिंग लाइक किड का आई थिंक
आई थिंक सचिन कैन सेंड थे लिंक
इन थे ग्रुप इस नो एडमिन क्योंकि मुझे ऋषभ
का एक्चुअली मुझे मिल नहीं रहा था
ग्रुप सो डेट सबको पता जिनको नहीं पता खैर
उनको पता चल जाए फिर से एक बार और दे कैन
जॉइन ओके
चलिए तो कहां पर है यूनिक नॉन नेगेटिव
इंतजार से इनको दिनो किया जाता है सिंपल
सी चीज ओके
डिस्क्रिप्शन
ठीक फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन होता ही होता है हर
एक ओपन फाइल के लिए बस इतना दिमाग में
आपको रखना है यू हैव तू ऑलवेज कीपिंग मन
ओके
क्रॉस प्लेटफॉर्म की तरह आप इसको समझ सकते
हो यह आपका सबसे पहले फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
जो था यूनिक्स में उसे हुआ था ठीक है अभी
आपका लिरिक्स में
कंटिन्यू आपका उसे हो रहा है ठीक है और
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विंडोज में इसको फाइल हैंडल
बोलते हैं फाइल हैंडलिंग जो आप जानते
होंगे बेसिकली फाइल हैंडल्स इसको बोलते
हैं इसको फाइल हैंडल्स बोलते हैं विंडोज
में
यूनिक्स लाइनेक्स की बात कर रहे हैं कर
रहा हूं मैं फाइल
हैंडल्स जो बोलते हैं ये हम बोलते हैं
विंडोज के अंदर
एक चीज अब जो है दूसरी चीज पे आते हैं और
इसको समझते हैं की एक्चुअली जो ये आपका
इनपुट आउटपुट ये जो स्पेशल फाइल्स है ये
जो फाइल डिप्रैस है इसका एक्चुअल
कॉन्सेप्ट थोड़ा सा समझते हैं ठीक है अब
देखो
जो भी आपका इनपुट होता है जो भी आपकी
आउटपुट होती है जो भी एरर मैसेज होते हैं
जो आपके टर्मिनल पे जो डिस्प्ले होते हैं
ठीक है वो सारे स्पेशल फाइल्स हैं जैसे
मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया ठीक है और उनका
एक लोकेशन होता है जहां पे वो रहते हैं
उनका एक लोकेशन है भाई आपका भी लोकेशन है
आपका भी घर है ठीक है इस तरीके से उनका भी
एक लोकेशन होता है जहां पे वो रहते हैं
सिंपल सी चीज है ठीक है नो
लेट सी लुक वो क्या कैसे कहां पे वो रहते
हैं वो मैं आपको बताता हूं ठीक है जैसे
मैं आप एक टेबल टाइप बना देता हूं मैं
यहां पे बता देता हूं
स्पेशल फाइल्स की टेबल स्पेशल फाइल्स की
टेबल यहां पर हो जाएगी यहां पर उसके
कॉरस्पॉडिंग फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
में बना देता हूं
ओके
स्पेशल फाइल्स लोकेशन
दे देते हैं लोकेशन ऑफ स्पेशल फाइल्स ठीक
तो पहले जो होता है
भैया एसटीडी इन एसटीडी इन यह कहां पर
रिकॉर्ड होता है स्लैश देव स्लैश एस टी दी
आई एन दूसरा जो होता है आपका वो होता है
स्लैशदेव स्लैश एसटीडी आउट ठीक है भाई और
तीसरा जो होता है भैया वो आपका होता है
आपका
यह आउटपुट के लिए हो गया
स्लैशदेव स्लैशनल यह जो है ना आईएसपी भी
हम आएंगे यह एक तरह का आपका ब्लैक होल है
जैसे आप ब्लैक होल जानते हो वैसे ही ब्लैक
होल है इसके अंदर जो भेजोगे गायब हो जाएगा
ठीक है तो ये एक आईएसपी भी हम आएंगे लेटर
ऑन पहले हम इन चीज इन तीन को देखते हैं
चलिए अब एसटीडी इन जो है आपका देव स्लैश
एसटीडी इन इसका जो फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
कॉरस्पॉडिंग है ये जीरो से दिनो होता है
एसटीडी आउट वन से होता है एसटीडी
तू से होता है
तो इसका जो रीडायरेक्ट सिंबल होता है जीरो
ली दें
ठीक है उसके बाद इसका होता वन ग्रेटर दें
इसका होता है तू ग्रेटर
है तो भैया
डिस्क्रिप्शन का उसे करते हैं
यानी अगर इनपुट आपको देना है तो आप ये
सिंबल उसे करोगे आउटपुट के लिए यही सिंबल
उसे करोगे और आपको एरर्स को अगर रेडित
करना है तो आप को ये उसे करना है ठीक है
और भी बहुत साड़ी चीज हैं जो अभी मैं
बताऊंगा लाइक और पर सेंड होता है
हम उसमें भी आएंगे बट पहले इस चीज को समझो
ठीक है यहां मैं इस कंडोम कर देता हूं
ताकि ये जो गोला घेरा है जाएगा ओके
अब अब ये सिंगल
करता है
मतलब की अगर आपने किसी फाइल में ऑलरेडी एक
आउटपुट दे राखी है अगर आप इसका उसे करते
हैं दूसरे आउटपुट के लिए तो पहले वाले
आउटपुट को वो रिमूव कर देगा हटा देगा ठीक
है और अगर आप डबल ग्रेटर दें का उसे करते
हैं तो उसमें क्या होगा की जो पहले वाले
आउटपुट होगी वो भी रहेगा और जो दूसरा आप
डालेंगे वो उसमें जाके एड हो जाएगा अपेंड
हो जाएगा पेंट का मतलब सीधा एड हो जाना
होता है एक्सट्रैडिशन हो गई ये इसका फायदा
है थॉट्स आईटी बाकी कॉन्सेप्ट हमारा यही
है क्लियर इतना सबको क्लियर है किसी को
कोई प्रॉब्लम लेट मी नो किसी को कोई
प्रॉब्लम
प्लीज लेट मी नो
किसी को कोई प्रॉब्लम होगी तो प्लीज आप
चाट में बता सकते हैं आपके बेसिकली सचिन
सर की तबीयत थोड़ी ठीक नहीं थी तो लाइव
सेशन नहीं ले पाते बट आपके डाउट्स के लिए
एटलिस्ट है वो
ठीक है वो भी ले सकते हैं आपके आयुष सर भी
हैं तो
ठीक है
अब देखो इसमें क्या होता है अगर आपको किसी
फाइल में आउटपुट भेजनी है ना आउटपुट तो
किसका उसे करोगे
अगर किसी फाइल में आउटपुट भेजनी है किसका
उसे करोगे
सिंपल इसका उसे करो
कन्ज्यूरिंग कॉन्सेप्ट है कुछ लोगों को
थोड़ा लेट समझ में आएगा बट बिलीव मी एक
बात एकदम बिलीव करो इस चीज को की आप लोगों
को लेट सपोज लाइफ में थोड़ा कुछ समझ में
नहीं ए रहा है ना अगर लेट सपोज तो यू कैन
वॉच डी रिकॉर्ड वीडियो जो लाइव खत्म होने
के बाद युटुब पे ऑलरेडी ए जाति है ना उसको
दोबारा देखना उसे चीज को जहां-जहां समझना
आपको क्लियर हो जाएगा फर्श और क्लियर हो
जाएगा ठीक है अभी मुझे कहानी एक फाइल में
आउटपुट भेज ना तो यू बिल उसे दिस फाइल डॉट
जैसे मुझे अगर डेट कमांड भेजना है तो ये
मैंने उसे किया इसके जगह पे इसके जगह पे
आप सिंपली डेट कमांड के बाद ग्रेटर डेन भी
ओनली लिख के
कर सकते हो यह भी दोनों से से ही है
ठीक है बहुत हार्ड से तो यह किसके लिए
आपके स्टडी आउट के लिए
अब यह लोकेशन आपको मैं थोड़ा दिखा देता
हूं ताकि आपको थोड़ा विजुलाइज भी हो जाना
चाहिए ना यू शुड बी विजुलाइजिंग आईटी सो
लेट सी डी लोकेशन जो लोकेशन हमने अभी देखा
हमने पता किया इसकी लोकेशन जो होती है देव
के अंदर में होता है तो आप देव जो होता है
फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर ही आपको मिलेगा फाइल
सिस्टम में आप जाएंगे तो देवर इस एन
डायरेक्टरी देव इसमें जाएंगे तो यहां पे
आप सर्च कर सकते हैं लाइक किड ऑफ एस टी दी
एसटीडी सर्च करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको मिल
जाएगा ये तीनों एक लाइन से आपको दिखे रहे
हैं एसटीडी एलसीडी इन एसटीडी आउट ये तीनों
आपकी फाइल्स हैं ठीक है इसी में हमारे
नल भैया भी मिल जाएंगे जो देव नल की में
बात कर था वो भी यही पे मिल जाएंगे ये
फाइल्स कुछ भी नहीं है लेकिन बहुत कुछ कम
करती हैं बहुत कम करती हैं कुछ है नहीं
इनके अंदर कुछ भी नहीं होगा लेकिन कम जो
है ना वो बहुत बड़े कम है इनके ओके चलो
अभी आते हैं आईएसपी अब देखो तो यह जो यह
तो क्लियर हो गया आपका कॉन्सेप्ट यह समझ
में ए गया होगा सिंपल सी चीज है अब यहां
पे स्क्रीन पे ए जाते हैं एक बार लेट कम
तू दिस स्क्रीन प्लीज जिनको क्लियर नहीं
होगा ना अगर लेट सपोज तो आप एक बार दोबारा
रिपीट कर लोग ना तो 110% क्लियर होगा
क्योंकि बहुत बेसिक से बता रहा हूं बहुत
सिंपल इसलिए मैंने आपको पहले फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन का कॉन्सेप्ट भी बताया क्या
होता है फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
नहीं बोलना डिस्क्रिप्शन है ये ठीक है
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन है डिस्क्रिप्शन
नहीं कर रहे हम यह दिस इस दिस
डिस्क्रिप्टर कभी मैं डिक्रैप्ट बोल डन तो
उसको इग्नोर कर देना ठीक है वो ए जाता है
मुंह पे दिस इस डिस्क्रिप्शन किया
और इसको मैंने इंक्रीज कर दिया थोड़ा सा
डिस्प्ले को अब यहां पर क्या करते हैं ना
डेस्कटॉप पर अलेक्स करते हैं
आई थिंक तो एक कम करता हूं मैं यहां पे
रूट डायरेक्टरी में चल देता हूं और मैं
रूट लोकेशन पे चल रहा हूं कैसे आपको पता
की ये कौन सा डायरेक्टर है तो पीडी और
कमांड इंटर करोगे प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी इससे पता चल जाएगा की आपका कौन
सा डायरेक्टरी है तो हम स्लैश रूट में
ऑपरेट कर रहे हैं फिलहाल के लिए ध्यान
रखिएगा ये जो कर ली जो है ना ये सिंबल
यहां पे आपको जो ये ये स्लैश रूट यहां पे
आपको शो कर रही है ठीक है और यहां पे आप
सीडी / चले जाएंगे तो ये बेसिकली आपको
कहां लेकर जाएगा ये वेयर आईटी बिल टेक
फाइल सिस्टम क्योंकि आप पीडी यहां पे
करोगे तो ये स्लैश के अंदर चला जाएगा तो
चलो अब यहां पे फिलहाल ये कॉन्सेप्ट आपका
क्लियर होगा ऑलरेडी तो अब यहां पे आते हैं
यहां पे हम ल एस करते हैं आपको ये सारे
डायरेक्टर्स आपको यहां पे दिखे रही है
नेक्स्ट टॉप डॉक्यूमेंट डाउनलोड म्यूजिक
पिक्चर्स
हम इस आउटपुट को जो हमने एलएस कमांड टाइप
किया ना इसी को उसे कर लेते हैं ठीक है
नो व्हाट वे टाइप ल एस पर आपको आउटपुट
क्या मिला ये आउटपुट मिला सामने स्क्रीन
पे अब मुझे ये आउटपुट ना यहां नहीं चाहिए
भाई आई वांट दिस आउटपुट तू बी इनसाइड ऑफ
फाइल क्या करेंगे
हमने क्या किया एसटीडी आउट उसे कर लिया
out.t
इसमें दाल देते हैं इंटर
सामने नहीं मिली दिस आउटपुट इसे बीइंग रीड
नो अलेक्स करो आउटडोर टक्स एक फाइल क्रिएट
हो गई होगी इसको व्यू करने के लिए कैट
कमेंट का उसे करो out.txt
इंटर करो और जो भी आपने इसमें भेजो था रीड
किया था वो यहां पे आपको दिखे गया है
क्लियर है इतना क्लियर है इतना क्लियर है
गैस प्लीज आपका क्लियर है बता दो जल्दी से
आपका ये जो है रीड डायरेक्ट हो गया अब
यहां पे मां लो लेट सपोज मुझे क्या करना
है मुझे जैसे मैंने ये कमांड उसे किया ना
वन ग्रेटर दें मैं बिना इसके भी कर सकता
हूं जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं मैं क्या करता
हूं ल एस करता हूं मैं यहां अलेक्स करता
हूं मैं
देता हूं और इसको फाइल डॉट फाइल में इसको
मैं इंटर करता हूं फिर भी आपका हो जाएगा
फाइल और टेस्टी बन गई है कैट कमांड से
फाइल और टेस्टी ओपन करोगे आपके सामने जो
एंट्री थी सिंपल मतलब आप ग्रेटर दें उसे
करो या सिंपली ग्रेटर दें उसे करो थॉट्स
जो प्रणाम
एक और चीज एक और चीज आपको मैं बताता हूं
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज अब यहां पर आपने
दिखे गई मोबाइल अब यह क्या हुआ
टैक्सी देख रहे हो तो उसका मतलब क्या है
व्हाट आईटी मिंस समझ
इन का उसे कर रहे हो एसटीडी इन
क्योंकि आप फाइल और टक्स को कैट के इनपुट
में दाल रहे हो समझ में ए रहा है यह
कॉन्सेप्ट यह कॉन्सेप्ट बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
है ऐसे सोचोगे ना तब समझ में आएगा देखो हम
बेसिकली क्या कर रहे हैं ना हम सिर्फ कैट
कमांड नहीं चला रहे हैं ये तो नॉर्मल सा
कमांड है जो हम सबको बताया जाता है दिस इस
एन वेरी जेनेरिक कमांड जो हम सबको बताया
जाता है सिंपल ये बहुत ही जल्दी कमांड है
है ना हम यहां पे कुछ और भी कर रहे हैं वे
आर डूइंग समथिंग एल्स तू हम यहां पर
एक्चुअल ओरिजिनल क्या चला रहे हैं हम यहां
पर ओरिजिनल चला रहे हैं कैट
0 एसटीडी इन
ठीक है
कंटेंट को इनपुट दे रहे हैं
आप लोगों को मुझे एक बात बताओ जल्दी से
सभी आंसर करो चाट में आम करेंटली रीडिंग
डी चाट मैं अभी चाट रीड कर रहा हूं तो
मुझे बताओ जल्दी फटाफट
ओके
ठीक है यह कॉन्सेप्ट आपको जल्दी जनरली
क्या होता है नहीं बताया जाता है यह
कॉन्सेप्ट क्या होता है जनरली आपको नहीं
बताया जाता है ओके
यह कॉन्सेप्ट आपको नहीं बताया जाता है
आपको सिंपली कैट कमांड का उसे बता दिया
जाता है की कैट स्पेस फाइल और टैक्सी हम
उसे कंटेंट को व्यू कर सकते हैं बट
एक्चुअली में व्यू हम व्यू क्या कर रहे
हैं हम तो एसटीडी इन दे रहे हैं कैट को और
उसके बाद बोल रहे हैं की भैया दिखाओ
क्योंकि कैट कमांड का कम ही होता है की वह
चीज प्रिंट करके देगा जो भी फाइल के अंदर
आपके कंटेंट्स हैं
ठीक है
तो फाइल का इनपुट यहां पर अब इंटर करो
देखो फिर भी आपको दिखेगा फाइल अब इसकी जगह
पर यू कैन उसे दिस अलसो यू कैन उसे विदाउट
जीरो अलसो देखो से से आपकी आउटपुट ए गई
है
सिंपल
सा कॉन्सेप्ट था बहुत ज्यादा कुछ नहीं था
और इसका
एक और
तरीका एक और स्टैंडर्ड कमांड क्या हो सकता
है जो एक्चुअली हम उसे करते ही नहीं है वह
एक्चुअल कमांड क्या होना चाहिए इसका की
कैट
ठीक है
इनपुट दे रहे हैं भाई तो हमने क्या किया
कॉन्सेप्ट
समझ में ए रहा है आपको
डिटेल आपको कोई नहीं बताया वह भी आपको एक
फ्री कोर्स के अंदर में इस बात की मैं
गारंटी देता हूं
बट हमने प्रॉमिस किया तो उसको पूरा करेंगे
कॉन्सेप्ट नहीं समझ में आया अरे यार इतना
इजी है नहीं समझ में आया मैं बताता हूं
मैं सिंपल बताता हूं
मैं यहां पर समझता हूं नहीं आया ना मैं
समझता हूं देखो देखो देखो भाई मैंने क्या
बताया था यहां पे
एसटीडी आउट सॉरी ये जो एसटीडी आउट है भाई
एसटीडी आउट ये किस पे किसके लिए है किसी
भी तरह के आउटपुट को हम यहां भेजते हैं जो
भी आउटपुट होती है यहां आपकी आई है इसमें
हम बेसिकली आउटपुट को यहां रीड करते हैं
बस इतना समझ जो
यह कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा तो यह समझा रहा
हूं की हम आउटपुट को शो कर रहे हैं जो की
हम भेजते हैं देव एसटीडी आउट और इंटर करो
से आपको मिलने वाली है आउटपुट
सिमिलर आउटपुट
यह तो समझ में इतना तो बहुत इजी होगा
क्लियर हो गया होगा मेरे ख्याल से यह आपको
से आउटपुट देगा लेकिन एक चीज आपको यहां पे
देखनी होगी एक चीज आपको समझनी होगी क्या
समझनी होगी की जब आप कैट file.t करोगे ना
इंटर यहां पे इस तरीके से तो ये से आपको
से आउटपुट यहां पे मिल रहा है बेसिकली
फाइल और टेक्स्ट के अंदर की जो भी
कॉन्टेक्स्ट है जो भी चीज है वो आपको मिल
रही है यहां पे और यहां पे आपको बेसिकली
इसके पास भी से आउटपुट मिल रही है बट एक
जो स्टैंडर्ड कमांड होता है ना आपका वो
आपका ये होता है ये आपका स्टैंडर्ड कमांड
है दिस इसे डी मोस्ट स्टैंडर्ड कमांड डेट
वे शुड उसे बट वे डोंट उसे बिकॉज़
ऑन इस वही हमारा मोटिव है कॉन्सेप्ट को
क्लियर करना है बाकी नॉर्मल तो कोई भी
कहानी पे भी बता देगा आपको कहानी पे भी
मिल अगर इंटरनेट पर फ्री में मिल गया
अवेलेबल
स्टैंडर्ड जो कमांड है ना उसको उसे किया
है पर वीविंग और फाइल्स या कंटेंट ऑफ
फाइल्स थॉट्स आईटी
बस
समझ में ए गया अब एक चीज एक चीज इसमें हम
मैं और करना चाहूंगा एक चीज मैं और क्या
करना चाहूंगा आपको बताना चाहूंगा
अब अगर मैं ऐसा करूं कैट देखो लिरिक्स में
कमांड से खेलोगे तो बहुत मजा आएगा बहुत
मजा आएगा इंटरेस्टिंग लगेगा तुमको बर तो
लगेगा ही नहीं अब देखो कैट यहां लिख दिया
अब मैं ये
वाली चीज यह वाली चीज नहीं करना मुझे
तो इस तरह से करके यह तो एंट्री चीज हो
जाएगी आपकी आउटपुट वाली चीज हो जाएगी तो
ये वाली चीज आपको नहीं करनी अब देखो वो
रिमूव हो गई होगी आप एलएस करो मैंने वो कर
दिया था ना अब यहां पे कैट फील्ड और
टेस्टी करो इसके अंदर कोई इसे भी एंट्री
नहीं है ठीक है
हम उसे पर भी आएंगे हम अभी फिलहाल के लिए
क्या कर रहे हैं बट लाइक व्हाट वे आर
गोइंग तू डू हमने क्या किया था इसके
आउटपुट जो भी आउटपुट ए रही थी तो हम ल एस
ल एस करके और एलएस को हमने फाइल डॉट यहां
पे दाल दिया था जैसे हमारा फाइल और
टेक्स्ट क्रिएट था और फाइल में ये साड़ी
हमारी एंट्रीज थी
ठीक है अब हम क्या करते हैं ना हमें कमेंट
चलते हैं कैट और यहां पर अब देते हैं भैया
ली दें सिंबल
ली दें
ठीक है
और इसको रीडायरेक्ट करते हैं कहां पे
स्लैशदेव एसटीडी आई एन
हमने इसको किया एसटी इन में अब अब इंटर
करोगे ना अब स्केट फाइल और टक्स को रीड
करोगे तो यहां कुछ भी नहीं मिलेगा
तो यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है
यस जीरो इस इंक्लूड यहां पर
समझ में ए गया बिल्कुल बहुत सिंपल था
ठीक है
ठीक
है
बस इतना समझना है की ये ग्रेटर और एक चीज
और समझनी है की ग्रेटर दें जो सिंबल है
सिंगल वो वैरायटी के लिए और डबल अगर करते
हैं तो ये होता है हमारा अपेंड करने के
लिए
ठीक है
अब मुझे अब आप फाइल क्रिएट करते हो तो आप
क्या करते हो फाइल क्रिएट करते हो तो आप
बहुत तरह की फाइल क्रिएट करने के अलग-अलग
तरीके होते हैं है ना लाइक टच कमांड से
फाइल क्रिएट होती है टच कमांड दिया एक या
फाइल क्रिएट हो गई है ए नाम की फाइल की
डेट हो जाएगी फिर उसके बाद फाइल क्रिएट
करने के लिए विम विम का उसे करते हैं विम
कमांड का भी उसे होता है फाइल क्रिएट
मैंने बी नाम से फाइल बनाया विम का ये
फाइल यहां है
आप पढ़ेंगे आने वाले टाइम में और यहां पे
बी नाम की फाइल क्रिएट हो गई ठीक है इस
तरीके से आप फाइल क्रिएट करते हो
आईएफ यू वांट ग्राफिकल तो माउस पद से सी
नाम की फाइल क्रिएट कारी तो ये ग्राफिकल
ओपन हो जाएगा और यहां पे सब्सक्राइब तू
डिफरेंट अकादमी ये टाइप किया और से किया
और यहां से बाहर ए गया तो ये भी एक फाइल
की डेट हो गई एवं आप कैट कमांड से भी फाइल
क्रिएट कर सकते हो करते हो कैट
ठीक है कैट उसके बाद
दी नाम की फाइल क्रिएट करनी है तो यह
ग्रेटर डेन और
ग्रेटर दें
व्हाट इसे डूइंग
कर रहा है दी नाम की एक फाइल में
जो फाइल एक्जिस्ट करेगी तो ये फाइल बना
देगा अब जो बना देगा तो ये पूछ रहा है
भैया क्या रीडायरेक्ट करना है मतलब कुछ
डालना है की ऐसे ही आप कैट कमांड कोड रीड
आउट कर दिया उसमें
तो कुछ करना है तो हां कुछ अगर टाइप करना
है तो हेलो हेलो कुछ भी टाइप करना है तो
टाइप कर दो नहीं
बन गई
रीडायरेक्ट सिंबल का उसे करके कर लेना है
तो कैसे बनेगा
[संगीत]
तो यह आपका तरीका होता है फाइल को क्रिएट
करने
का बेसिकली हम क्या कर रहे हैं हम आउटपुट
दे रहे हैं डेट्स आईटी
बस अच्छा अब आते हैं यहां पर
कॉन्सेप्ट को समझते हैं
जिसको हम को समझना है और ये जो कॉन्सेप्ट
है ना इसको हम बोलते हैं टी कमांड
थोड़ा मुझको भी समझ लेते हैं क्योंकि
हमारे पास ज्यादा टाइम नहीं है बट स्टाइल
वे बिल कंप्लीट आईटी थोड़ा सा वेट करेंगे
थोड़ा थोड़ा टाइम लेंगे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है हम एक कमांड देखते हैं टी इससे कनेक्ट
है इसलिए मैं इसको बता दे रहा हूं ठीक है
टी कमांड का अब मां लो आप जो लाइक
जो भी आपका आउटपुट ए रहा है
और उसको आप बेसिकली क्या करते हो की किड
ऑफ यू कैन अंडरस्टैंड की उसको आपको एसटीडी
आउट को भी देना है
ठीक है
दोनों चीज करनी है भैया
मतलब जो आउटपुट है उसको स्क्रीन पर भी
चाहिए और फाइल में भी चाहिए
यह करना है आपको तो यह इस तरह की चीजों
में आपका जो है ना टी कमांड उसे आता है
यह साड़ी आपके
उसे करते हो वहां पर क्या उसे करते हो
वहां पर उसे करते हो
अब जब दो कमांड आप उसे करते हो जैसे पाइप
क्या करता है ना जैसे ये पाइप है यह पाइप
का उसे करने के लिए और का उसे होता है
यहां पर एक यहां पे सिंपल क्या है ये पाइप
है ये ठीक है
लेट सपोज ओके और पाइप के बाद आपने ग्राफ
कमांड ग्राफ नाम की एक कमांड लिखने
ठीक है
पहले कमांड जो पहले कमांड है पहले कमांड
के आउटपुट को
आउटपुट को दूसरे कमांड का इनपुट बना दे
देगा
गो आईटी ल एस का जो भी आउटपुट होगा ना
ग्रेप के लिए वह इनपुट हो जाएगा
और अपनी कम करेगा ठीक है तो ग्रिप का कम
बेसिकली अभी के लिए अगर समझो एकदम सिंपल
सा भाषा में ग्रिप ग्रिप का उसे हम
बेसिकली कोई भी स्ट्रिंग सर्च करने के लिए
कोई रेगुलर लाइक कोई भी किसी भी तरह का
एक्सप्रेशन वो सर्च करने के लिए हम करते
हैं कोई भी स्ट्रिंग कोई भी पर्टिकुलर
स्ट्रिंग आपको सर्च करनी हो किसी फाइल के
अंदर में किसी भी उसके अंदर में तो आप वो
ग्रेप का उसे करते हो
मां लो की मैं एलएस कमांड उसे करता हूं
यहां पर इंटर करता हूं हमारे कल पट मिलती
है अब मुझे क्या करना है ल एस उसके बाद
में पाइप का उसे करता हूं और मुझे सारे
आउटपुट नहीं चाहिए मुझे चाहिए ग्रुप में
फिल्टर आउट करता हूं सर्च करने के लिए और
मुझे सिर्फ वो आउटपुट चाहिए जो शुरू होते
हैं
और इंटर करूंगा तो यहां पर जो आउटपुट
मिलेगा यह देखो यह एक पर्टिकुलर स्ट्रिंग
को सर्च करता है उसके अगेंस्ट आपको रिजल्ट
शो करता है तो मैंने एलएस किया तो एलएस के
आउटपुट को जो की आउटपुट में ये सर आता सर
ये सारे आते हैं एलिस का आउटपुट में इसका
इनपुट बनाया पाइप ने ग्रेप को और ग्रेप का
कम होता है स्ट्रिंग वाइस सर्च करना जो भी
आप पर्टिकुलर स्ट्रिंग वहां पे दिखा रहे
हो दे रहे हो वो उसको सर्च करेगा तो उसे
स्ट्रिंग के अकॉर्डिंग ये सर्च करके और
आपको दी से जो भी स्टार्टिंग जो भी दी से
स्टार्टिंग आपके पास डोकम डायरेक्टरी
फाइल्स हैं वो आपको दिखा देगा
इसलिए मैंने आपको ये पाइप वाली चीज बताई
ठीक है
जब आपको किसी भी फाइल में रीडायरेक्ट करना
हो प्रिंट भी करना हो दोनों कम करना हो तो
टी कमांड का उसे करते हैं जैसे कोई आउटपुट
है अगर आपको चाहते हो की वो स्क्रीन पे भी
प्रिंट हो और किसी फाइल में रीडायरेक्ट भी
हो जाए तो वे उसे टी का मां
तो इस टाइप के रीडायरेक्शन के लिए हम
टीकमगढ़ उसे करते हैं थॉट्स आईटी तो यहां
भाई अलेक्स करते हैं
ठीक है
आपको पता है अब क्या करते हैं एलएस और
यहां देते हैं सॉरी यहां देते हैं ग्रिप
सॉरी ग्रेप का उसे नहीं करते हैं टीका उसे
करते हैं टी ल एस के बाद यहां देते हैं टी
अब हमें रेड करना है तो अब किसी एक फाइल
में करनी है हमें ऑब्वीजली इसको
रीडायरेक्ट कहां पे करेंगे किसी भी जगह पे
कर सकते हैं वॅटीवर प्लेस वे वांट जो भी
चीज में आपको करना है तो यहां पे मैंने
फाइल देता हूं टेस्ट डॉट टी एक्स टी ये
फाइल है और इंटर कर देता हूं तो अब क्या
होगा गैस यहां देखो इसमें क्या किया
टेस्ट डॉट टी एक्स टी में भी इस आउटपुट को
इसने रीडायरेक्ट कर दिया होगा और यहां पे
स्क्रीन पे भी शो कर दिया थॉट्स आईटी
सिंपल ये फंडा है अब तुम देखो टेस्ट और
टेस्टी बनी है की नहीं ये देखो टेस्ट डॉट
टेक्स्ट ये बन गई है अब टेस्ट को व्यू
करोगे तो इसके अंदर सॉरी कैट टेस्ट डॉट टी
एक्स सी इसके अंदर वो साड़ी फाइल्स होगी
समझ में आया ये चीज समझ में आई बहुत सिंपल
सा था मैं एक बार फिर से थोड़ा सा समझा
देता हूं क्लियर कर देता हूं बेसिकली टी
कमांड का जो उसे होता है वो क्या उसे होता
है तू प्रिंट डी आउटपुट और अलसो रीड
डायरेक्ट तू ऑफ फाइल
तो हमने जब यह कमांड चलाया
तो यहां पाइप का उसे किस लिए किया क्योंकि
एलएस का जो आउटपुट होगा जो भी इस प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी में जितने भी फोल्डर
हैं फाइल्स हैं उनको पास करना है आगे
इनपुट टी कमांड को अब टी कमांड ने अपना कम
करना शुरू कर दिया क्या करेगा ये टेस्ट और
टेस्टी में भी दाल देगा
और इसको प्रिंट भी कर देगा यानी की
रीडायरेक्ट भी कर रहा है और भैया प्रिंट
भी कर रहा है
अब चाहते हो की ना मुझे
अपेंड भी करना है तो सिंपल एक कमांड जो
होती है वो लगा लोग
इससे आपको अपेंड करने का भी यह अप और कर
देगा
इंटर कर डॉग तो बेसिकली क्या होगा यह
टेस्ट जो है ना इसको अपेंड कर देगा जैसे
अब मैं करता हूं यहां पर कैट टेस्ट डॉट
टेक्स्ट यहां देखो
हमने बेसिकली क्या किया हमने और कुछ भी
नहीं किया हमने अपेंड कर दिया हमने जो
आउटपुट पहले आई थी वही आउटपुट दोबारा भेजो
लेकिन रिप्लेस करके ना अपेंड करके खत्म
बस यह थी इस तरीके उसे करते हैं
अभी मैं एक चीज जो मैंने अभी थोड़ी डर
पहले बताई थी होता है हमारा
[संगीत]
कैप्चर करने के लिए बेसिकली होता है
किसी भी तरह के आउटपुट को आपको दबाना है
सरप्राइज करना है किसी भी तरह कोई भी
आउटपुट हो तो आप ये कम कर सकते हो
ठीक है मतलब की यह कैसे कम यह बेसिकली
एसटीडी के लिए आपका उसे में आता है एसटीडी
जो आपने देखा था कुछ टाइम पहले एरर्स के
लिए जो बेसिकली मैंने आपको बताया था आई
थिंक दिस वन इस नो नो दिस वन इसे डी
कौन सा था यार फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
यह वाला एसटीडी
इसके लिए
बता देता हूं
मैं किस तरीके से किस तरीके से हो सकता है
देखो
मतलब कोई ऐसी फाइल डायरेक्टर नहीं है तो
यह ना रीड करेगा ना कुछ ना कुछ बनाने का
आपने कुछ आउटपुट का नहीं दिया कुछ भी नहीं
दिया तो ये एरर ए गई कैट हेलो नो सर्च
फाइल और डायरेक्टरी
मुझे क्या करना है ना मुझे क्या करना है
की इस एरर को टाइप कर देना है
तो क्या मैं क्या करूंगा कैट हेलो मैंने
लिख दिया अब मैं इसको एसटीडी का अगर आपको
याद होगा गैस तो मैंने रीडायरेक्ट सिंबल
आपको इसलिए बताया हुआ था एसटीडी एरर का यह
देखो एसटीडी का रीडायरेक्ट सिंबल क्या था
भाई
ये ध्यान रखिएगा तू ग्रेटर है तो मुझे
क्या करना है तू ग्रेटर दें
स्लैश देव फ्लैश नल
कहानी खत्म
प्रेस कर दिया खत्म कर दिया बेसिकली हमारा
यही है बस एरर को हमने सरप्राइज करके खत्म
कर दिया सिंपल
ग्राफिकल
ओके हम हम तो रूट के अंदर थे ना ठीक है
रूट के अंदर यह रहा error.t इसको विजुअल
थोड़ा सा देख लेते हैं ये देखिए इसके अंदर
ये एरर आपकी प्रिंट होके ए चुकी है मतलब
इसमें ए चुकी है
ठीक है अब यह रीड डायरेक्ट का भी मैं आपको
सिंबल आपको रीड डायरेक्ट वाला भी बता देता
हूं एरर वाली जो है ना एरर वाली ये मैं
आपको रीडायरेक्ट वाली चीज आपको एक सिंपल
सा एक चीज बता देता हूं देखो
ये रहा ये देखो यहां पे
डायरेक्ट एसटीडी आउट
तू एन
फाइन रीडर
की बात करें
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन की तो यहां पर एसटीडी
आउट फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन होता है ना उसमें
हम एम पर सेंड वन का उसे करते हैं अगर
आपको फाइल एसटीडी आउट क्या एक फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन होता है एम पर स्टैंड वन
इसको हम बोलते हैं आपका
अब इसका कम क्या हो जाता है
सिंपल
यह करनी है और एरर सोल्स
कैपचरिंग भी करना है
और आउटपुट को भी आपको एक फाइल को सेंड कर
दिया
एग्जांपल
[संगीत]
हो जाए तो उसको करने का देखो अभी क्या है
जैसे की मां लो व्हाट आई एम गोइंग तू डू
मैं क्या करता हूं ना मैं तो पहले एक तो
ओपन टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेट हूं और इसको मैं
जूम कर लेट हूं इस तरीके से और यहां पे ल
एस करता हूं मैं यहां पे ये साड़ी फाइल्स
है चलो अच्छी बात है ये साड़ी फाइल्स हैं
ठीक है व्हाट आई एम गोइंग तू डू ना मुझे
मैं एक कम करता हूं मैं एक छोटा सा
स्क्रिप्ट एक छोटा सा स्क्रिप्ट लिखने हैं
छोटा सा स्क्रिप्ट जो कुछ करेगा बेसिकली
आप बेसिकली आपको अगर आता है तो आप बेस्ट
में कर सकते हैं या तो आप गुप्त का हेल्प
भी ले सकते हो सिंपल सा होता है बहुत
ज्यादा वो नहीं है तो मैं क्या करता हूं
विम और मैं करता हूं
बना देते हैं डायरेक्टली
बनाने का एक छोटा सा स्क्रिप्ट करते हैं
जिसमें हमें बेसिकली दिखाना चाहिए की क्या
हो रहा है किस तरीके से चीज ताकि हमें
उसका आउटपुट और उसमें एरर्स जो है ना वो
की हमें आने चाहिए इस तरीके से कुछ हमें
देखना है तो मैंने एक स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट
में एक छोटा सा स्क्रिप्टिंग कर रहा हूं
छोटा सा बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग आप बैच बोलते
हो उसको बेसिकली तो हम इसका छोटा सा
स्क्रिप्टिंग करते हैं ठीक है ना तो अभी
देखो मैं यहां पे बेसिकली मैंने इनपुट
यहां पे एंट्री इंसर्ट मोड ऑन किया विम के
अंदर में अगर आपको नहीं पता तो विम के
अंदर में इंसर्ट मोड ऑन करने का ये सर कुछ
आपको बताया जाएगा टेंशन नहीं लेनी है ठीक
है तो
स्लैबेंज कर देते हैं और यहां पे नो
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग तू डू एक छोटा सा
स्क्रिप्ट लिखने हैं पर आई वेरिएबल या इन
ठीक है अब मुझे चाहिए डायरेक्टली बनानी है
तो मैं डायरेक्टली बना देता हूं ए पांच
डायरेक्टर बनाता हूं ए से लेक आई तक ए बी
सी दी आई ये पांच डायरेक्टर भैया बनाया
हमने यहां पे कर दिया अब क्या करना है जब
ए से ए तक फ्री
तो आपको क्या करना है डू ठीक है
एक करेंगे और इसको कुछ भी कर देंगे
क्रिएटिंग
क्रिएटिंग डायरेक्टली ऐसे कर देते हैं और
इसको हम बनाते हैं क्योंकि हम कोई भी
टेंपरेरी कम अभी ये टेंपरेरी एक स्क्रिप्ट
है टेंपरेरी कम करेंगे स्क्रिप्ट जो है
टेंपरेरी आपकी डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करने
वाली है तो हम टेंपो में करते हैं टीएनपी
/ टीएमटी और बेसिकली क्या करेंगे यहां पे
आपको एक यहां पे डॉलर से आई को यहां पे
दिनो करना पड़ेगा ताकि जो ये वेरिएबल की
तरह कम होगा की बार-बार जब ये पर चलेगा
लूप चलेगा आपका बेसिकली जो भी हमने कंडीशन
डिफाइन किया है यहां पे लूप के लिए पर के
लिए की ए तू ए तक बनाना है हमने यहां पे
इसको ना ये नहीं रखा है ए लूप में ट्रू
करके छोड़ नहीं दिया की बांदा ही जाएगा
बांदा ही रहेगा रुकेगा नहीं हमने यहां पे
भी बेसिकली पर लूप का उसे किया है कंडीशन
दे रही है ए तू ए नाम की एक ए बी सी दी आई
पांच डायरेक्टर ही आपको बनानी है उसके बाद
रुक जाना है बस सिंपल सा चीज है ठीक है तो
हमने क्या किया एक क्रिएटिंग का
डायरेक्टरी स्लैश टीम पे बनाना है आपको
कौन सी बनानी है आई वाली बनानी है ए फिर
आओ बी फिर आओ सी इसलिए हमने वो डॉलर का
सिंबल किया है ठीक है वेरिएबल आपको असाइन
कर दिया आपको दिनो कर दिया वो अब यहां पे
आई से ये चीज बना देगा इसको हम ब्रैकेट
इसको हम क्लोज करते हैं नो यहां पे अपना
डायरेक्टली बनानी है तो मकदीर और
डायरेक्टर कहां बनानी है तो टीएमटी में
पंप के अंदर में और फिर से वही कम का है
टीएनपी के अंदर में आपको डायरेक्टली बनानी
है ठीक है तो यहां पे डॉलर
और आई अगेन वे बिल गिव और डेट सीट एक गलती
हमने यहां पे कर दी है गलती क्या किया
यहां हमने पे हमने यहां पे टीम के अंदर
बनाना है ना की हमें वैसे तो हमें पूरा
पार्ट्स डिफाइन करना पड़ेगा स्लैश स्टेम
स्लैश उसके बाद हमें बनानी है ना
डायरेक्टली तो ये चीज हो गई तो वो से गाइड
यहां पे दिनो कर देगा बता देगा जो भी
डायरेक्टर बनेगी तो यहां पे हमने ये चीज
एक स्टेप लिख दी और थॉट्स आईटी यहां पे
दान कर देते हैं हो गया हमने छोटा सा
स्क्रिप्ट तैयार किया अब इसको चेक कर
लेंगे की ये चल रहा है की नहीं चल रहा है
तो हमने इसको बैंड किया ब्लू की से कर
दिया इसको स्क्रिप्ट को और डेट सीट अब हम
क्या करते हैं स्क्रिप्ट को एग्जीक्यूट
करते हैं या डॉट एस हा और अभी देखो ए से
ही तक का एलएस करते हैं यहां ऑलरेडी
फाइल्स है ए से ए तक का तो मैं इन फाइल्स
को रिमूव कर देता हूं ए बी सी दी आई ये
फाइल्स को मैं रिमूव कर देता हूं आई थिंक
रिमूव हो गई होगी आई थिंक हां रिमूव हो गई
है ठीक है ना ये कम कर देना यार इसको चेंज
कर देते हैं इसमें ए से ए तक नहीं बनाते
हैं
करेंगे यहां पे दोत इंटर करेंगे अब जैसे
ही हमने इंटर किया गैस यहां पे हमारे साथ
एक पंगा हो गया ये हमारा लाइनेक्स जो है
वो बोल रहा है की भाई हम तो
लाइक वे बिल नोट एग्जीक्यूट एग्जीक्यूट
नहीं करेंगे
क्यों परमिशन नहीं है भाई रूट से फिर भी
परमिशन
इंटर करोगे यहां पर तो आपको दिखेगा की तीन
परमिशन आपको पता होगी तीन परमीशंस बेसिकली
आपको होती है रीड राइट एग्जीक्यूटिव तीन
चीज होती है रीड राइट एग्जीक्यूट यूजर
ग्रुप और अदर के लिए आपका यह यूजर हो गया
यह आपका ग्रुप हो गया सॉरी ये आपका ग्रुप
हो गया और ये आपकी अदर की परमिशन हो गई तो
यूजर को यह जो दास आपको शुरू में दिखा रहा
है ये एक फाइल को दिनो करता है यहां पे
अगर दी रहेगा तो वो डायरेक्टली को दिनो
करेगा सिंपल सी चीज है है ना तो अब यहां
यूजर को रीड राइट की परमिशन है एग्जीक्यूट
की परमिशन नहीं है ग्रुप को रीड की परमिशन
है ओन्ली और आदर्श को रीड की परमिशन है तो
हमें यूजर के लिए तो चाहिए ना रूट के लिए
तो हमें रु तो है एक्स का परमिशन नहीं है
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन नहीं है तो हम इसको
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन दे देंगे तो सी हा
मोड
सॉरी
रीड राइट एग्जीक्यूटिव कमीशन मिल गई हमारे
को थॉट्स आईटी यही तो चाहिए था तो हमेशा
मिल गई तो दादा स्लैश डॉट स्लैश दिया है
डॉट एस हा इसको हम एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे नो
जैसे एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे यहां पे आपके पास
सामने जो आउटपुट मिल रहा क्या मिल रहा है
क्रिएटिंग ए डायरेक्टरी टेंप वन तू थ्री
फोर फाइव अब देखते हैं अलेक्स करके डायरी
बनी है क्या
व्हाट इसे दिस ओके टेंप में बनी है सॉरी
टेंपो में बना रहा है ना हम तो हमें टेंप
में जाके देखना होगा ना सीडी स्लैश टीएनपी
इंटर एलएस करो इंटर करो देखो यहां पे भाई
डायरेक्टली बनी है की नहीं बनी है यहां पे
दिखे जाएगा आपको सिंपल ऊपर चलते हैं ये
देखो ये देखो ये देखो एक दो तीन कर पांच
ये डायरेक्टली बन गई आपकी सिंपल क्लियर बन
गई जो हमने डायरेक्टर बनाई वो बन गई भाई
बहुत अच्छी बात है तो हमारा स्क्रिप्ट कम
कर रहा है अब क्या करते हैं ना अब क्या
करते हैं मैं वापस
दोबारा चलते हैं इंटर करते हैं अब जब
दोबारा हमने चलाया ना दोबारा तो ये क्या ए
रहा है क्रिएटिंग का डायरेक्टर
मतलब ऑलरेडी एडजस्ट कर रही है तो हम नहीं
कर सकते
समझ में ए गया नो अब हमें इसको सरप्राइज
करना है
यू आर गोइंग तू उसे और वन उसका उसे हम
करेंगे क्योंकि हम एक फाइल में भी चाहिए
और हमें एरर को भी लॉक करना है वहां पे
फाइल में आउटपुट भी चाहिए एरर को भी लॉक
करनी है भाई तो अब हम क्या करते हैं ना
डॉट स्लैश दिया यार सर डॉट एस हा डियर
सर्च बोल रहा हूं मैं दे आर सर्च किया आदत
हो गई है तो डॉट स्लैश दिया या डॉट एस हा
और इसको हम एक आउटपुट देते हैं
किसी फाइल में दे दो
[संगीत]
ये ऑलरेडी तो क्या करता हूं मैं दी डॉट
स्लाइड स और इसको देते हैं
ये कन्ज्यूरिंग हो जाएगा तो मैं ए जाता
हूं डेफ्रॉनिक्स डॉट टेक्सी
ले में हम ले जा के डालते हैं और इसको जब
डालेंगे तो आप क्या करेंगे
यहां पे सामने आप चलते हैं कहां पे वे आर
गोइंग तू
करते हैं
आपको दिखे रही है क्या
नहीं दिखे रही है
आपको दिखे रही है क्या अच्छा नहीं दिखे
रही है क्यों नहीं दिखे रही है यह भी बता
दो जरा कोई समझ कोई बता सकता है अन्योन
कैन तेल लाइक ए वे आर नोट सीन डिफरेंस अभी
हमने ऊपर आउटपुट फाइल यहां पे दिया यहां
पर हमने यहां जो लिखा यह डिफरेंस
है हमने तो सबको सही किया सही किया क्या
गलती है
व्हाट इसे डी मिस्टेक अरे भाई हमने आउटपुट
रिएक्शन दिया कहां यहां पर डॉ सच के बाद
आउटपुट रे डायरेक्शन तो देना है ये मिस कर
देना हमने तो वो तो देना है भाई अभी लो
अभी लो अभी यह कमांड दिया था हमने यहां पर
आउटपुट रे डायरेक्शन दिया कहां पे ये वाला
है
अब हम इंटर करते हैं
मतलब हमने एरर्स को सरप्राइज कर दिया
बिल्कुल गायब कर दिया बट अब हम ल एस
करेंगे
वो सारे जो है आपको यहां पे
मिल जाएंगे एवरीथिंग हर
सिंपली आउटपुट को एक फाइल में दाल दिया इस
कमांड का मतलब क्या हो गया देख लो आउटपुट
को एक फाइल में दाल दिया
उसे फाइल में भी दाल दिया और हमें वो फाइल
में साड़ी चीज दिखे गई उसको सरप्राइज कर
दिया
समझ में ए गया अब यहां से देव नल को भी
उसे कर लो ठीक है
आप उसको उसे कर सकते हो इतना समझ में आया
सबको क्लियर हुआ सबको अभी तक नो इट्स टाइम
थोड़ा सा लंबा हो गया बट ठीक है चलेगा
यहां पे हम क्लोज कर देंगे बट आई डोंट
वांट की आपको आ की आई डोंट वांट की मुझे
पता मतलब ऐसा मुझे नहीं चाहिए की आपको समझ
में ना आया हो और फिर आप निकाल जो हालांकि
थोड़ा बहुत जो बेसिक कॉन्सेप्ट है वो आप
अगर दोबारा रिपीट करोगे वो नहीं समझ में
आएगी तो रिपीट करोगे समझ में ए जाएगा बहुत
ही सिंपली मैंने ट्राई किया है आपको समझने
का बहुत ही परिसर कॉन्सेप्ट अगर मैं अगर
आपको बताऊं सच में तो परिसर कॉन्सेप्ट है
और एक सेशन में पूरा नहीं होगा अभी आपको
बहुत साड़ी चीज जो है बेसिक जो है ना
मैंने बेसिकली मोस्टली प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट
पे फॉक्स करके थोड़ा आपको थ्योरी का भी टच
देखिए आपको समझने की कोशिश की है तो इट्स
एन ह्यूज टॉपिक उसे कॉन्सेप्ट फाइल अपने
आप में कॉन्सेप्ट है बहुत बड़ा यार ये जो
चीज हैं बहुत बहुत साड़ी चीज इसके अंदर
में तो बट थोड़ा-बहुत आपको समझ में ए जाना
चाहिए और इसका रेट एक और हम सेशन ट्राई
करेंगे उसमें ये चीज क्लियर करने की कोशिश
करेंगे ठीक है
ओके
सो ठीक है तो आई थिंक आई थिंक
इतना काफी है आज के लिए
आज के लिए इतना काफी है
तो आई थिंक आज के लिए हम इसको यही पे रॉक
देते हैं यही पर हम आज के सेशन को कंप्लीट
करते हैं और करते हैं आई होप आपको क्लियर
हो गया होगा आपको समझ में ए गया होगा
साड़ी चीज क्लियर बिल्कुल हो गई होगी और
अगर आपका क्लियर नहीं हुआ तो मैं बस एक ही
चीज बोलूंगा प्लीज प्लीज
रिपीट डी वीडियो जब भी आपके युटुब पे
वीडियो क्योंकि सेशन जैसी और होगा आपकी
वीडियो जो है ए जाएगी युटुब पे उसको आप
रिपीट कर दो और आपका जो है कम वो बेसिकली
हो जाएगा थॉट्स आईटी रिपीट कर डॉग खत्म हो
गया आपको बिल्कुल ही क्लियर हो जाएगा जो
भी क्लियर होना बैक गया था बिल्कुल ही
क्लियर हो जाएगा
ओके समझ में ए गया
चलो नेक्स्ट स्टेशन में हम इसको कंटिन्यू
कर सकते हैं जो भी चीज कुछ र गई है वो भी
कर लेंगे ठीक है और
और प्लीज अटेंडेंस को मेंटेन करो प्लीज
अटेंडेंस को थोड़ा मेंटेन करो और उसे चीज
को थोड़ा सा क्योंकि अटेंडेंस में जितना
मेंटेनेंस रखोगे लाइफ में जो मजा है ना वो
आपके रिकॉर्डिंग में नहीं आता है आई नो आई
नो वेरी वेल सो प्लीज और अपने दोस्तों के
साथ शेर करो लाइक आईएफ यू नो लाइक आईएफ यू
आईएफ यू नो कोई बांदा है जिसको जरूर है
उसे इसकी
इस नॉलेज की तो उसको शेर करो दोस्तों के
साथ आईटी बिल बी वेरी हेल्पफुल
और आने के लिए
ठीक है
हमारे इस फ्री लाइव कैप्सूल कोर्स में और
आप अगर सपोर्ट करना चाहे तो शेर कर सकते
हो वीडियो को अपने दोस्तों के साथ अपने
सोशल मीडिया और एल्स पर ताकि सब जगह पर यह
पहुंचे ओके थैंक यू सो मैच गुड